tous les avis sont unanimes y avait du
bon et du moins bon marqué il est quand
même plus de moi un bond de bon hein
enfin tout le monde est d'accord à la
télévision pour se faire une idée il
faut attendre la deuxième ou la
troisième quand même la quatrième ou la
cinquième
des fois la sixième ou la septième
fourni je vois également rappelé les
ambitions de cette émission
ce sont celles du service public faire
de la qualité sans oublier l'audience
sans négliger la qualité tout en faisant
de l'audience c'est très clair n'est ce
pas être content d'être revenu en
deuxième semaine
ah bah oui on aime ça on est très
content c'est vrai pour nous ça nous
fait une sortie enfin bon c'est surtout
pour vous parce que on a vu quand même
les résultats de la semaine dernière la
personne qui nous a montré les ce qu'est
ce qui a marché ce qui n'a pas marché
bon bah c'est exactement ce qu'on vous a
bein oui oui et contrat social vous êtes
là à main quand vous a dit ça on aime
bien aimée avec téléspectateurs ils ont
aimé aussi et puis quand on vous a dit
ça sentait moins c'est plus tard on dit
pareil ça prouve bien qu avec ma femme
on est pile dans dont la sensibilité du
public
donc si vous avez envie que ça marche
bien il faut nous écouter viendrait
peut-être en troisième semaine
un tout petit je crois que le dispositif
est au point
1 oui l'animateur entre le marteau de la
direction et l'enclume les
téléspectateurs je reconnais vraiment
épuisé puisque nos téléspectateurs
moyens parlait des résultats de la
semaine dernière on et faire un petit
bilan avec un premier constat de la
séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'est le clip de
michael jackson vous aviez programmé
avec un résultat formidable notamment
sur les 15 17 ans en bretagne et sur
les 13 21 ans dans le roussillon et là
je dois rendre hommage à votre flair et
aux grands professionnels vraiment
michael jackson il fallait y penser j'en
suis comme deux ronds de flan je savais
où enfin c'est pas si difficile là vous
mettez le doigt sur le secret des grands
programmateur de télévision les
qu'ancien les brière les gens qui
connaissent très bien leur métier moi
c'est tout simple j'avais remarqué que
michael jackson avait vendu à peu près
450 millions d'albums qu'il était
deuxième au top 50 et un soir j'étais au
restaurant avec ma femme et je lui ai
dit michael jackson on va programmer
naiken jackson
et ça marche on fait ce qu'on pourrait
faire un petit bilan de l'est
naturellement thierry c'est la tradition
et c'est prévu
ce petit bilan est là je dois une
nouvelle fois vous tirer mon chapeau
vous ment boucher un coin la séquence
thierry qui a fait le meilleur score la
semaine dernière c'est celle de michael
jackson dans thriller
[Applaudissements]
extraordinaire vous aviez le choix entre
nicole croisille où michael jackson est
là avec un flair incroyable avec un pif
désormais légendaire vous avez choisi
michael jackson s'est on peut dire
vraiment que vous avez mérité cette
fameuse médaille de grand pif du paf qui
vous avait été décerné à la semaine
dernière comptant les 7 d'or ont tout le
monde sait bien que c'est truqué en
faveur du service public ça vaut rien et
le grand pic du paf qui rit vous l'avez
vraiment mérité mais si on le regardait
sans talent se remplissent d'une miss
alpes maritimes
j'ai l'honneur de vous remettre au nom
du peuple français
le pif du paf merci ont la bonne idée
que vous avez eue la semaine dernière le
drame une fois merci
grèce les i
parce que peut vous à moi c'est la
télévision de a jusqu'à z
et oui c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
on savait ce qui est désolant mairie
service qui est désolant c'est que d'un
côté avec ce genre de trouvaille vous
nous fait gagner de l'audience
et puis de l'autre va vous allez faire
le zozo place de la concorde et qui
pleurnichent gagner et ce n'est pas un
bon calcul
vous y croyez vous le bilan de la
semaine dernière mais oui thierry en
effet le bilan c'est maintenant de
tradition dans hardy matt est bien la
séquence qui a fait le meilleur score la
semaine dernière c'est janet jackson
c'était votre idée et la tuerie en trois
émissions trois idées géniales vous est
ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la télé
bien ces quelques applaudissements mais
là malheureusement cette fois ci ce soir
tout magicien que vous êtes j'ai bien
peur que vous ne puissiez plus trouver
une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur au je me suis
dit n'y aurait-il pas un jackson blanc
parce que vous savez que michael jackson
se donne beaucoup de mal pour être blanc
celui-là et blanc inouïe ouais et
comment vous est venue cette idée
géniale thierry et si je peux me
permettre de vous le demander
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme
j'étais un peu pompette pompe est
exactement way et vous mangiez koala des
côtelettes d'agneau professeurs et puis
soudain l'idée est venue nous et je me
suis dit un jackson blanc
oui il ya thierry comme il est
maintenant de tradition dans cette
émission un petit bilan de la semaine
dernière la séquence qui a réalisé le
meilleur score la semaine dernière c'est
le clip de joe jackson ce qui était
votre idée et l'attiré coup de chapeau
en quatre émissions quatre idées
géniales vous est ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision
[Applaudissements]
non
je crains que tout magicien que vous
êtes cette fois-ci vous ne puissiez plus
trouver une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
germaine jackson le frère de michael
jackson et oui thierry mais comment vous
est venue cette idée géniale j'étais au
restaurant avec ma femme et ma femme un
frère il n'échangeait quoi sans un
discrédit côtelettes d'agneau
professeurs
et j'ai pensé oh vous avez associés et
sur les frères des frères frères
bouleversant 1 et j'ai pensé à jermaine
jackson via série comme il est
maintenant de tradition un petit bilan
de la semaine dernière alors la séquence
qui a le mieux marché la semaine
dernière c'est le clip de jermaine
jackson et ça c'était votre idée alors
thierry vraiment en cinq émissions cinq
idées géniales
vous êtes vraiment ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télévision
là maintenant cette semaine tout
magicien que vous êtes je crains que
vous ne parveniez plus à trouver une
unité du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
jackson alors professeur et bien à
thierry comme il est désormais de
tradition un petit bilan de la semaine
dernière la séquence qui a le mieux
marché et la semaine dernière c'était la
séquence jesse jackson et ça c'était
votre idée et la tyrie vraiment en six
émissions 6 idée géniale vraiment on
peut dire que vous êtes ce qu'on appelle
un magicien de la télévision mais cette
semaine tout magicien que vous êtes j'ai
bien peur que vous ne parveniez pas à
trouver une idée du même tonneau
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé là
je me suis dit est-ce que janet jackson
n'aurait pas mon chéri mais comment vous
est venue cette idée géniale
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme et
un seul coup en regardant ma femme il un
pasteur avec un frère je me suis dit
c'est janet jackson aurait pas comme ça
que j'ai trouvés près des îles vous
mangiez quoi ces indiscrétions et 4 et
agneaux prometteur dirait le temps
génial
[Applaudissements]
eh bien mon cher thierry un petit bilan
comme il est de tradition alors la
séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence la
toya jackson et ça c'était votre idée
dire il a vraiment en cette émission
cette idée géniale
vraiment on peut dire que vous êtes ce
qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision ça méritait bien ces quelques
applaudissements mais bon là cette
semaine thierry tout magicien que vous
êtes j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée du
même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé à
long beach ex la soeur aînée de michael
jackson à la lave et comment vous est
venue cette idée géniale tirer j'étais
au restaurant avec ma femme pour les
soeurs et vous mangiez quoi sans
indiscrétion vont enchaîner avec le
petit bilan qui est désormais de
tradition dans cette émission
la séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'était la séquence
consacrée à rebbie jackson et sa thierry
c'était votre idée est là vraiment en
huit semaines 8 idée géniale réellement
on peut dire que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle un magicien de la télévision
allait bien ces quelques
applaudissements et puis en même temps
cette semaine tout magicien que vous
êtes airs et j'ai bien peur que vous ne
parveniez plus à trouver une idée du
même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé
allons les chapeaux jackson chapeau
belge égal mais excusez moi shérif il un
discret mais comment vous est venue
cette idée géniale
ce restaurant que ma femme mais le
vous mangez quoi 101 doucement fumée
professeur jean thierry volet de
l'émission qui commence dans la joie la
bonne humeur et la franche poilades
posément mais alain les jeunes comme il
est désormais de tradition je vous
propose un petit bilan de la semaine
passée la séquence qui a le mieux marché
la semaine dernière c'était la séquence
consacrée au chapeau jackson et saint
thierry c'était votre idée est là
vraiment voulais tu le dis c'est pas ça
méritait bien ces quelques
applaudissements extrêmement spontanée
et bien je vous disais réellement en
neuf semaines neuf idées géniales
honnêtement on peut dire que vous êtes
ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la télé
lire
[Applaudissements]
été bien fait quelques applaudissements
très spontané et puis en même temps
cette semaine en 10e semaine 1
j'ai bien peur que tout magicien que
vous êtes vous ne parveniez +1 a trouvé
une idée du même tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur j'ai trouvé ah
ouais il écoute alors tendez cela moi
veut ni un phil jackson extraordinaire
jackson comment vous est venue cette
idée géniale
thierry bas j'étais au restaurant avec
ma femme et d'un seul coup je me suis
dit et de serveurs s'appelait philippe
vous mangiez quoi sans indiscrétion j'ai
mangé des côtelettes d'être nouveaux
professeurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus